[Music]
hours they're filming the incredible
tree climbing behavior of his lions
they're getting bigger they're getting
stronger and every day means that
they're closer to survival lions
occasionally climb trees all over Africa
but the two main areas where they climb
trees is here in Queen Elizabeth
National Park and also in lake manyara
and Tanzania they're all climbing and
they climbed these big candelabra trees
and these big fig trees so the news was
really sort of devastating we didn't
realise as to how much danger these cats
actually were in that village nearby the
pot I got off the phone I got an SMS and
then I yeah I mean I I was very
emotional I cried but it's a ranger they
spends more time than anybody
a guy called Jimmy kiss ember in who
spends hours every single day driving
around the study area telling the
tourists where the Lions are and he knew
them so intimately more intimately than
we did but it was it was it was a
devastating blow to everyone just
because they were the main pride that
everyone was looking at and and loved so
much
[Music]
they were poisoned because they were
eating livestock and the people that had
the livestock didn't have any money
these people are making a couple of
dollars a day and you can understand
that if one or two cows is all that your
family has you'd probably also poison
those those lions because they're there
your entire livelihood they're your
entire existence so it's it's something
that's just really unfortunate thing
there there is no villain in this story
you know if if it was some rich hunter
or some rich person that did this yes
that would be bad but this is this is
something that just points to like a
much bigger problem facing lion
conservation across Africa
you
[Music]